STABLE DEMOCRACY, BUT A
COMPETENT LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD RIGHT NOW.
>> WOW.
WHEN YOU LOSE CHALK TUDD, YOU
ARE IN TROUBLE.
THAT'S LIKE YOUR WIFE TESTIFYING
AGAINST YOU IN COURT.
THAT'S LIKE TURNING ON HIS
FAMILY, CHALK TUDD.
>> I SEE A POSSIBLE CHARACTER --
>> CHALK TUDD IS THE GREATEST
NAME I HAVE EVER COME UP WITH.
>> THE CHAOS OF BIDEN IS WHAT HE
CAMPAIGNED AGAINST.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE STEADY
HAND ON THE WHEEL.
HE WAS GOING TO BE BORING,
ESPECIALLY ON FOREIGN POLICY.
REMEMBER HE GAVE A SPEECH ON
FEBRUARY 4TH, AMERICA IS BACK?
NOW WE HAVE AN ABSOLUTE MESS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE BORDER.
AND OUR OLDEST ALLY FRANCE IS
CALLING US NAMES.
THINGS ARE NOT GOING WELL.
PWEFLT THING, IT WAS LATE ON A
FRIDAY.
THING IS THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO
RIGHT THIS ON COVID BOOSTERS.
TURNS OUT HE PUT THE KARLT IN
FRONT OF THE HORSE.
EVER HEARD THAT ONE?
AND SO NOW HE'S GOING TO TRY TO
GIVE A CLIMATE SPEECH TOMORROW.
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
BIDEN'S POLITICAL EROSION
PREVENTING DEMOCRATS FROM TAKING
IT TO REPUBLICANS ON THE DEBT
CEILING OR DEMOCRATS TO GET ANY
TRACTION ON ITS LEGISLATIVE
AGENDA WHICH IS COMPLETELY
FALLING APART BEFORE OUR EYES.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU WORKED IN
EROSION AFTER TALKING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DID THERE.
RIGHT?
>> I DIDN'T PLAN IT.
>> YOU DIDN'T PLAN THAT?
HERE'S MY THEORY.
THE ONLY REASON THE MEDIA IS
CALLING THIS STUFF OUT IS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
THEY'RE KIND OF BACKED INTO A
CORNER.
THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD DRAG JOE
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
THEY CAN'T ANY MORE SO NOW
THEY'RE LETTING HIM DROP.
>> THEY WILL TALK ABOUT
CREDIBILITY?
WHY WEREN'T YOU TALKING ABOUT
THAT WHEN JOE BIDEN STOOD UP IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AFTER THE AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL
AND SAID AL QAEDA IS NOT IN
AFGHANISTAN ANY MORE AND
AMERICANS CAN GET TO THE AIRPORT
IN KABUL AND OUR ALLIES ARE WITH
US?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THEY
STAND UP AND JUST LIE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND ACT LIKE WE DON'T
KNOW THE TRUTH OR CAN SEE THE
TRUTH.
CNN HAD A FULL SCREEN OF ALL OF
THE ISSUES THIS MORNING LIKE
REBUKE OF IMMIGRATION BILL, AND
THE LIST IT'S UNDER BIDEN
HEADACHES.
THE CRISIS AT THE TEXAS BRIDGE,
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THERE IS LIKE A
BIG POT HOLE ON THE BRIDGE THAT
NEEDS SOME QUICKRETE PUT THERE.
THESE CIVILIANS UNDER HEADACHE.
A HEADACHE IS WHEN YOU GET THE
SEATING CHART FOR YOUR
DAUGHTER'S WEDDING.
THESE ARE DISASTERS.
LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
>> THEY'RE LOOKING AT IT THROUGH
A POLITICAL LENS.
THIS MUST BE HARD FOR OUR GUY.
JESSICA, AS AMERICA KNOWS YOU
ARE WITH CHILD, WE WON'T GET
INTO THE EFFECTS ON THE CLIMATE.
WHEN YOUR CHILD IS BORN, HOW
WILL YOU EXPLAIN TO HIM OR HER
WHY YOU VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN?
>> WE HAVE PETER FLAG ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
LITTLE GENDER REVEAL.
>> OH!
>> KIND OF LIKE JOE BIDEN.
>> WE ARE SO EXCITED.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
IT'S A GIRL.
>> GOING TO BE ENORMOUS.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LINEBACKER
LINEBACKER.
>> TWO THINGS.
BY COMPARISON, I MEAN.
IN HIS DEFENSE.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT -- I WILL TALK
ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S PROBLEMS NOW.
CHUCK TODD, WHEN PEOPLE USE HIM
AS AN EXAMPLE, LIKE PEOPLE HOLD
UP JENNIFER RUBIN AND SAY
CONSERVATIVES ARE TURNING ON
TRUMP.
CHUCK TODD LOVES TO PLAY THE
BOTH SIDES GAME.
BUT THERE'S DEFINITELY, THE
HEADACHES ARE BAD.
THE DRONE STRIKE, EVEN THOUGH
THIS DOES HAPPEN AND IT HAS
SINCE THE MID 2010'S, WHEN YOU
HEAR SEVEN KIDS, THERE WERE NO
ISIS-K FIGHTERS GOTTEN IN THAT,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN STICK
WITH YOU, NOT ENTIRELY BRING
DOWN AN ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT DOES
STAND OUT ON THE LIST OF WHAT'S
NOT A NORMAL HEADACHE.
>> THAT'S PRETTY BAD.
PRETTY BAD.
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING WE CAN
DO FOR THESE FAMILIES, WHETHER
BRINGING THEM HERE.
SEEMS LIKE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
THE U.N. IS MEETING THIS WEEK,
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION, WHY?
>> GOOD QUESTION.
I'M SEEING TRAFFIC, SO I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE PLANS.
JOE INSTEAD OF FIXING PROBLEMS,
HE'S CREATING PROBLEMS.
LITTLE JESSE JR., DAD, THE ONLY
THING JOE BIDEN KNOWS HOW TO FIX
IS ELECTIONS.
JESSE JR.!
WHAT SHOWS HAVE YOU BEEN
WATCHING?
WATCHING THE KING OF LATE NIGHT.
I SAID, WHO, KIMMELL?
IT'S TRUE.
WHAT HE DOES, I MEAN, AT LEAST
THE ECONOMY IS GOOD, RIGHT?
DID YOU SEE THE MARKET TODAY?
>> ALL THE WAGE GAINS ARE
GETTING WIPED OUT BY INFLATION.
TAKING ORDERS FROM THE TALIBAN.
WE'RE GETTING HACKED INTO
SMITHEREENS BY THE RUSSIANS.
CARTEL CONTROLS OUR BORDER.
HE CAN'T EVEN GET ON THE PHONE.
THE GUY HAS NO JUICE WITH OUR
ENEMIES EITHER.
MEXICO SAID NO ON THE BORDER.
IRAN SAID NO ON THE NUKE DEAL.
OPEC SAID NO ON NO MORE OIL
PRODUCTION.
WHO SAYS YES TO JOE?
THE CHEFS AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
NO ONE SAYS YES TO JOE.
THE AP COMES OUT AND SAYS JOE
BIDEN IS SUFFERING FROM SET SOME
BACKS.
SET BACKS ARE SOMETHING YOU CAN
WATCH LIKE A COLD.
HE'S GOT A CASE OF THE SET
BACKS, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
DO PEOPLE FEEL LIKE WE JUST
SIGNED A QUARTERBACK WHO CAN'T
RUN OR THROW AND THE SEASON JUST
STARTED.
>> IT'S AN INVERT TO SET BACKS.
EVERY TIME SOMETHING SMALL
HAPPENED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THE WORLD WAS
EXPLODING.
THE WORLD WAS CHAOS.